advisor for international economics and
deputy director of the national economic
council he coordinates the
administration's policy-making process
for a range of issues at the
intersection of economic policy and
national security previously he was the
executive vice president and head of the
markets group at the new york federal
reserve where he led the implementation
for most of the fed's emergency
facilities launched during the pandemic
he served as an acting assistant
secretary for domestic finance at the
treasury department during the obama
biden administration as well as deputy
assistant secretary for international
affairs uh they will each give brief
remarks uh and then we'll take some
questions your introduction won't be as
fancy the second time you come but uh so
i think ann is starting
thank you very much jen good afternoon
it's good to see you all
over the last decade russia has used
cyber as a major part of its military
activity beyond its borders including to
undermine coerce and destabilize ukraine
for that reason and at the president's
direction we've been working to prepare
for potential cyber attacks since
november
we've been focused on doing so in three
ways first we've continued our urgent
work to shore up our cyber defenses at
home
second we've boosted our efforts
providing support to ukraine and third
we've worked closely with partners and
allies to defend against and disrupt
malicious cyber activity i'll expand on
each of these three areas
first we're shoring up our defenses at
home
while there are currently no specific or
credible cyber threats to the homeland
the u.s government has been preparing
for potential geopolitical contingencies
since before thanksgiving
the white house has coordinated
extensive outreach by agencies with the
private sector
specifically private sector owners and
operators of critical infrastructure
in that outreach departments and
agencies have gone to unprecedented and
extraordinary lengths to share sensitive
information and most importantly to
outline specific steps companies can
take to make their systems more secure
as one example of those specific steps
the department of energy shared
technical indicators
of techniques used by russian cyber
actors to conduct cyber attacks against
ukrainian electricity systems during
prior crises in ukraine
we're also using the authorities we have
to require companies to put in place the
cyber defenses needed for example tsa
issued directives that require oil and
gas pipelines to report cyber incidents
conduct vulnerability assessments and
exercise their incident response plans
tsa is now working to expand that to
both the aviation and railroad sectors
as many of you know the government
doesn't own or operate critical
infrastructure that provides critical
services to our citizens
for example our water and power systems
i cannot stress this enough we urge our
private sector partners to exercise
incident response plans and put in place
the cyber security defenses like
encryption and multi-factor
authentication that make cyber attacks
harder for even sophisticated cyber
actors
second
we continue to support ukraine as it
works to shore up its cyber defenses
the us government believes that russian
cyber actors
likely have targeted the us the
ukrainian government including military
and critical infrastructure networks to
collect intelligence and pre-position to
conduct disruptive cyber activities
these disruptive cyber operations could
be leveraged if russia takes further
military action against ukraine
we've seen troubling signs of malicious
cyber activity this month
earlier this week we saw a kind of cyber
attack known as a ddos attack that
overloads online services at the
ukrainian ministry of defense and
state-owned banks
there were also text messages sent to
bank customers telling them that atm
services were unavailable
russia likes to move in the shadows and
counts on a long process of attribution
so it can continue its malicious
behavior against ukraine and cyberspace
including pre-positioning for its
potential invasion
in light of that we're moving quickly to
attribute the ddos attacks
we believe that the russian government
is responsible for wide scale cyber
attacks on ukrainian banks this week
we have technical information that links
russian the russian main intelligence
directorate or gru
as known gru infrastructure was seen
transmitting high volumes of
communication to ukraine-based ip
addresses and domains
we've shared the underlying intelligence
with ukraine and with our european
partners
while of limited impact this recent
spate of cyber attacks in ukraine are
consistent with what a russian effort
could look like and laying the
groundwork for more disruptive cyber
attacks accompanying a potential further
invasion of ukraine's sovereign
territory
we've been preparing for this
possibility
since november we further intensified
our support to the government of ukraine
specifically to network defenders
working to help them respond to and
recover from cyber incidents as well as
strengthen the resilience of cyber
critical infrastructure
finally we're cooperating with allies
and partners to disrupt and respond to
malicious cyber activity that includes
work to share intelligence regarding
malicious cyber techniques and ensure
the global community is ready to rapidly
call out militia cyber activity as
appropriate
members of the administration have met
with leaders across the region to
discuss cyber resilience deterrence of
cyber attacks and to ensure we're
prepared to address any cyber
contingencies we've met with our polish
and baltic counterparts our nato allies
and our european partners including
france and germany
the global community must be prepared to
shine a light on malicious cyber
activity and hold actors accountable for
any and all disruptive or destructive
cyber activity
and as the president said earlier this
week if russia attacks the united states
or our allies through asymmetric
activities like disruptive cyber attacks
against our companies or critical
infrastructure we are prepared to
respond
thank
you afternoon everybody
mr president biden has said if russia
attacks ukraine we will respond
decisively and forcefully to impose
costs on russia alongside our allies and
partners
the cost to russia would be immense both
to its economy and its strategic
position in the world our financial
sanctions have been designed to impose
overwhelming and immediate costs to the
largest financial institutions and
state-owned enterprises in russia
they've been calibrated to maximize
alignment with our allies and partners
they're flexible to allow for further
escalation or de-escalation depending on
how putin responds
and they're responsible to avoid
targeting the russian people and to
limit unwanted spillovers to the u.s and
global economy
we're also prepared to impose powerful
export controls as part of our response
package
both financial sanctions and export
controls deny something to russia that
it needs
and can't get from anywhere other than
the united states or our allies and
partners
financial sanctions deny foreign capital
to russia
and export controls deny critical
technological inputs that russia needs
to diversify its economy
and to deliver on putin's strategic
ambitions in aerospace defense and high
tech
working in tandem financial sanctions
and export controls are embedded in a
broader strategy that would undercut
putin's aspirations to project power and
exert influence on the world stage
if russia invades ukraine it will become
a pariah to the international community
it will become isolated from global
financial markets and it would be
deprived of the most sophisticated
technological inputs
russia would face the prospect of
intense capital outflows mounting
pressure on its currency
surging inflation higher borrowing costs
economic contraction
and the erosion of its productive
capacity
taken together russia will become more
dependent on countries that cannot
compensate for its losses this would be
a strategic defeat for russia pure and
simple
meanwhile the west and international
community
would emerge more united and determine
to defend shared values and core
principles than at any point in the
post-cold war era
we're ready to impose costs in lockstep
with our allies and partners because we
share the belief that russia has no
right to redraw its neighbors borders by
force and that countries have the
freedom to set their own course and to
choose their own destiny
to be clear the test of unity with our
allies and partners is not whether our
actions are matched to the letter or
whether our implementation mechanics are
identical
the test of unity is whether we share a
recognition of the core principles that
are at stake
whether we share the resolve to defend
those principles by imposing severe
costs on russia for its actions
and whether we're willing to do all we
can to support each other and managing
the consequences
i can tell you with confidence that
we've met the test
and on this last point since i know many
of you have asked let me say that we are
in active engagement with major energy
consumers and major energy producers to
coordinate potential actions to
stabilize energy markets and all of our
tools are on the table thank you
are you still discussing elements of the
sanctions package among yourselves or is
the package ready to go as soon as the
invention begins
you know i i would say at this point we
are we are converging on the final
package
and
anybody who's worked on
sanctions in the eu or the us or any
other allies and partners would say that
the unity and coordination that we've
seen in the past few months is unlike
anything we've experienced
and that's the reason i say that the
west is likely to emerge more unified
and determined coming out of this
episode than at any point in the
post-cold war era
could you talk a little bit about the
export control measures how would they
impact russian electronics yeah so uh
the reality is that the west and open
societies this is where innovation and
entrepreneurship flourish we produce the
most sophisticated technological inputs
across a range of foundational
technologies
ai quantum biotech
hypersonic flight robotics
as we and our partners move in lockstep
to deny these critical technology inputs
to russia's economy
putin's desire to diversify outside of
oil and gas which is two-thirds of his
export revenue half of his budget
revenues
that will be denied
he's spoken many times about his desire
for an aerospace sector a defense sector
an i.t sector without these critical
technology inputs there is no path to
realizing those ambitions
thank you so much um and this is a
follow-up for you if i can um it sounds
like and just put a fine point on this
you have assessed now that russia was
behind the cyber attacks against the
defense ministry and the banks in
ukraine can you tell us specifically
when you assessed that how extensive it
was and obviously you've been warning
for days that that type of
an action could be a precursor to a
russian invasion
have you been able to determine whether
those actions were taken to send a
signal that yes
so yes we we have assessed um that
russia was responsible for the
distributed denial of service attacks
that occurred earlier this week and i
will note that the speed with which we
made that attribution as you know is
very unusual
and we've done so because of a need to
call out the behavior quickly as part of
holding nations accountable when they
conduct disruptive or destabilizing
cyber activity you asked how extensive
that activity was
it was of limited impact because
ukrainian cyber defenders rapidly
brought back the both state-owned banks
and the ministry of defense networks
and indeed
we have provided support to our those
ukrainian network defenders to ensure
that they are prepared for even more
potentially extensive
behaviors or activities and then finally
we do believe as i noted that russia
does use cyber as part of its projecting
force whether that is influencing
coercing or destabilizing
so we do expect that should russia
decide to proceed with a further
invasion of ukraine we may see further
destabilizing or destructive cyber
activity and we've been working closely
with allies and partners to ensure we're
prepared to call out that behavior and
respond when needed uh follow if i can
you've talked about the extensive uh
steps that you have taken and that you
have tried to encourage the private
sector to take as well to be prepared
for potential cyber attacks are you
confident
is the private sector prepared is u.s
government prepared for a russian cyber
attack
can americans feel as though their money
is safe and that u.s entities are safe
we are confident that we have worked
closely with the private sector to press
critical infrastructure owners and
operators in the private sector to take
the necessary steps to deploy cyber
defenses we've shared sensitive
information we've shared most
importantly the specific steps and we've
exercised the maximum of government
authorities to mandate those steps as
needed we know that should anything
occur we'll work closely with the
private sector to rapidly respond and
recover kayla thank you so much i have a
question
for each of you but i'll ask delete
first
the administration and other world
leaders have said now for months that
sanctions
uh will be swift and severe and they
will be the most powerful deterrent to
an invasion
but now with all of these signs that an
invasion
is
going to come in the next few days or as
likely is that a sign that vladimir
putin has calculated that the cost is
bearable for russia
you know look i know there's a lot of
talk about whether russia has a
sanctions proof economy and there really
is no such thing as a sanctions proof
economy if you if you think about the
term sanctions proof
it means that a country is deciding to
de-integrate from the global financial
system that means less foreign capital
higher borrowing costs less investment
and lower growth
and look whether you're an autocrat or a
small d democrat every leader cares
about your economic conditions it's part
of the social contract you have with
your people and let's think about the
baseline in russia
right now russia has an inflation rate
of 8.7
the central bank of russia has raised
interest rates eight times over the past
year to nine and a half percent the
ruble is the worst performer among any
emerging market currency that's before
that's before any sanctions have been
imposed
and if we impose these sanctions which
are the most severe measures we've ever
contemplated against russia
you don't have to take my word for what
would happen look back to 2014 with a
much less severe package
we saw record capital outflows we saw a
weakening of the ruble by up to 50
percent
we saw russia spend 25 percent of its
foreign reserves in a futile attempt to
defend the ruble
we saw interest rates spiked to 17
we saw inflation spike to 17
and the economy fell into recession
and the vicious feedback loop we saw in
2014 was determined by putin's own
choices not prescribed in advance by us
the more he escalates the more pain he
feels
so look uh there's no question in my
mind that putin is not playing a winning
hand and it's not just sanctions the
export controls deny him the critical
technologies he needs to develop his
economy over time
if he invades europe is going to
accelerate its diversification away from
russian energy supplies we'll fortify
nato's eastern flank
all of these actions not just sanctions
deal putin a very weak strategic hand
and um you said that
if russia targets companies or
institutions here and i'm wondering what
intelligence the u.s has that it can
share about how that may figure into
russia's campaign
so as i said there are no specific or
credible cyber threats against the
homeland
but we're making clear that we're
preparing for that in case of any
contingencies
on that note what's your level of
concern that there could be an online or
cyber attack against say the banking
system in the u.s should russia decide
to invade
as we know you know as a society we're
very connected and digitized society and
that as a society we don't have the
level of cyber resilience that we wish
to since the beginning of the
administration president biden has made
both domestic and physical resilience a
priority and we've urgently taken
significant steps whether there are new
authorities the president's executive
order working closely with the private
sector in unprecedented ways
those serve as a foundation
for a far stronger domestic cyber
resilience we have today than at the
beginning of the administration but on
the other hand one should always prepare
for any contingencies and we've been
doing so sharing sensitive information
encouraging private sector owners and
operators to do the work they need to do
to lock their digital doors and
essentially do the equivalent of putting
on an alarm so one can rapidly identify
if there is an intruder and quickly
contain and respond have you already
seen that probing from russia
we consistently see probing activity i
think the department of defense talks
about the millions of probes it receives
consistently from criminal and
nation-state attackers we see that
regularly the key is to have the
resilience to be able to detect and
rapidly recover from any destructive or
destabilizing activity
usually those sanctions affect the
ordinary people we've seen them in
africa and the other countries are you
concerned that assumption that you may
impose on russia may end up affecting
ordinary people and not putting itself
yeah i mentioned some of the
we we have a set of guiding principles
that drive our design and sanctions they
need to be strong enough to demonstrate
our resolve we calibrate them to
maximize the chance of coordinating with
allies and partners
they're also responsible we we target
them carefully to avoid even the
appearance
of targeting the average russian
civilian and
where you'll see these sanctions applied
is on the
the commanding heights of the russian
economy and the russian state that's
where they're designed and so
where you see most of the force of
sanctions back in 2014 and where you'll
see them again now is through the
financial sector
and in areas where
putin needs critical technologies to
develop an industrial base
that's where these measures are
concentrated and it's meant to be
responsible
not to have contagion to the average
russian civilian you just returned from
west africa you went in drc and we see
in africa we have cools in africa people
cruise and attempted code is there
anything the u.s can do maybe relocating
africa from germany to africa
well our our efforts in africa and
across the developing world are to give
countries a better choice than they've
been receiving so we are uh we're on the
road offering infrastructure finance
that expresses our values so finance
that is transparent that's inclusive
that's sustainable uh infrastructure
financing that has high labor standards
high environmental standards
and infrastructure finance that
mobilizes our private sector which is
our key competitive advantage for too
long countries have not had a choice
they've had an opaque coercive and
extractive model of infrastructure
finance and that's why we're out to
compete because we think we have a
better product
can you say why the launch has been
delayed
you can just try that because we're
going to get to as many people as
possible and and that's what we're
trying to do here
and you alluded to this but the u.s has
assessed that uh the russians likely
have a foothold of the critical
ukrainian infrastructure on the
cyberspace right now is it the
expectation or is it a likelihood that
they will once again try and shut down
ukrainian power and if so is that
considered a red line for the u.s in
terms of a cyber operation response
so russia has used offensive cyber
activity um to coerce and disrupt
critical infrastructure in ukraine
during a prior crisis
so we would expect based on prior
activity that should russia decide to
proceed with an invasion of ukraine and
i want to be clear that our priority as
the president has noted is really
exercising every diplomatic option
possible to avoid that
we
are prepared for and have been working
with ukrainians and our european allies
and partners to help the ukrainians
prepare for
potential destructive or destabilizing
activity would that be a red line for
the like for the us in terms of a cyber
response i think as the president has
made clear disruptive or destructive
attacks against the u.s or allies
is of significant concern it's outside
the boundaries of international norms
particularly attacks against critical
infrastructure
we're going to get to as many as
possible
real quick and i think you alluded to
this at the end your opening statement
but we just heard from the prime
minister of italy mario jogging say that
sanctions should be focused on a limited
number of sectors uh without including
energy uh do you do that as a one-off
how do you address the fact that the
different countries particularly europe
have different equities here to try and
actually stay unified as you say
the west is right now i'll speak to the
energy question um first of all
our measures are not designed to reduce
or impair russia's ability to supply
energy to the world number two we think
it would be a strategic mistake for
putin to weaponize his energy supply
two-thirds of russia's exports and half
of its budget revenues come from oil and
gas
and if putin were to weaponize his
energy supply it would only accelerate
the diversification of the world away
from russian energy
consumption
number three we're prepared for anything
so if
if russia decides to weaponize its
energy supply we're ready
we've been taking steps as i mentioned
in my statement
to coordinate with major energy
consumers major energy producers
to ensure that we have steady energy
supplies and we have stable energy
markets on natural gas we've been
working with europe and lockstep to
surge natural gas to europe from north
africa from the middle east from other
parts of europe from the u.s and from
asia
and we've succeeded in largely
compensating for any shortfall that
could unfold if gas that flows through
ukraine is cut but the last point i'll
make
it's maybe the most fundamental one
policy involves trade-offs and the
president said this week he's not going
to pretend
that this is all painless but think of
the counterfactual think if russia's
aggression in the heart of europe went
unchecked
possibly the largest land invasion in
the post-cold war era think of the
uncertainties that would cause think of
the chilling effect that would cause
across the european continent think of
the questions that will be asked
about which other countries could be
bullied by
an autocrat looking to exert a sphere of
influence those are costs we're not
willing to tolerate rachel just a quick
follow-up to some of the intelligence
that you mentioned i know you said right
now the administration is confident that
there is no threat level to the united
states but how quickly do you expect
that to change if there is an invasion
and if and when sanctions are imposed
i won't get into the hypotheticals what
i will say is that we
focused on maximum preparedness across
government systems across private sector
critical infrastructure both in the
united states and working closely with
our allies and partners
thank you and um can you talk about what
companies in the private sector are the
most vulnerable obviously you've talked
about banking you've talked a little bit
about the water systems but what other
ones do you consider to be most at risk
right now and then i have a question for
you too absolutely so generally as we
look at ourselves as a society
we know that critical infrastructure is
our focus to rapidly improve our
domestic resilience because of the
degree to which critical services like
power and water touch citizens across
the united states and that's why some of
the most urgent and innovative efforts
that the president has initiated this
year have focused on those sectors from
the industrial control systems effort to
tsa's first exercise of its emergency
authorities to
nerc issuing an alert earlier this week
for the utility sector as well so that
is really the critical infrastructure
particularly power communications and
water have been a clear focus because of
the fact that
they touch americans lives and because
of the need to address the fact that
these sectors digitized quickly and we
need to catch up from a security and
resilience which we have made
significant progress on in this first
year
a quick question on the export tool
what technologies and products
can the us and allies withhold from
putin that he can't get elsewhere for
example from china
we think we have an asymmetric advantage
when it comes to the foundational
technologies of our time so think of ai
semiconductors quantum robotics
hypersonic flight
these are products that in almost every
case
are
designed and produced in the west and in
open societies we define the productive
frontier so there really is no ability
for russia to replace or compensate for
the denial of these inputs from anywhere
else including china
yeah uh actually just to follow up on
the china question um
i mean as we're dealing with the threats
of russia uh we know that you've also
been um
doing these tours to appetite and south
america in terms of promoting the build
back better world to counter the belt
and road initiative can you share a
little bit uh the level of interest to
this program from uh the countries that
you visited and why has there been a
hold up because the promise was that it
will be launched earlier early this week
this year
yeah i'll say there's been enormous
enthusiasm uh in every country we
visited ecuador colombia panama ghana
senegal the drc
uh parts of the middle east indonesia
thailand and other parts of the world
and the reason there's so much
enthusiasm is that countries do want a
choice
for a long time china has been
the only game in town for many of these
countries and in many cases they have
buyer's regret
the loans that have been made to these
countries have often been very opaque
they have non-disclosure agreements they
have termination clauses they have
confiscatory collateral arrangements
uh they're extractive in many cases in
the drc for example this is a country
that's rich in minerals over 20 trillion
dollars in critical minerals but they've
not seen the schools the roads the
hospitals the bridges they were promised
and so we're offering a different way
with as i say high standards for
transparency inclusivity uh development
impact local development impact uh and
very very strong attention to the labor
market impacts environmental standards
and you know so we're mobilizing along
with our g7 partners and we are going to
launch early this year you should see
very soon a list of flagship projects
that will exemplify exactly what blue
black better world is all about
thank you thank you
let me clarify is removing
russia from the swift international
banking system part of the financial
sanctions package well all options
remain on the table
but you it's probably not going to be
the case that you'll see swift in the
initial rollout package we have other
severe measures we can take that our
allies and partners are ready to to take
in lockstep with us and that don't have
the same spillover effects but we always
will monitor these options and we'll uh
we'll revise our our judgments as time
goes on
said you're gonna start
at the maximum that it wouldn't be like
a you know ramping up of sanctions i can
assure you the measures that we have
prepared
uh the severity of those measures and
the institutions that we would impose
them upon and the immediacy of those
sanctions
uh are among the most severe financial
sanctions that have ever been
contemplated
on the sanctions if there is severe as
you say
how do you protect against the risk that
russia's economy
becomes stitched even tighter with china
or others who might be able to avoid
what the us is doing so you can look at
this question from both perspectives
from russia's perspective if it wants to
sequester itself from western economies
western technology and western capital
markets and try to substitute china for
all that we provide
that's a very bad miscalculation the g7
alone represents more than 50 percent of
the global economy china's 15
uh if you look at the the dollar the
euro the british pound and the yen these
are the dominant reserve currencies of
the world it's how the world makes
payments how it's how it saves money
it's how the world borrows money the
remnant b share on these metrics is in
the low single digits and if you think
about the foundational technologies of
our time they are uh in almost all cases
designed or produced by the west and
open societies where innovation and
entrepreneurship flourish so
there is i don't think any question that
china could not be a substitute for all
the west provides now for china's part
uh if it decides to give tacit or
explicit accommodation to the invasion
of a sovereign nation in the heart of
europe that would be a very bad signal
for its vision of the world uh the
reputational effects it would have in
europe will be profound the signals it
would send all across the world about
its willingness to accommodate coercion
and force and aggression would have very
long lasting effects and let's be real
the russian economy is one tenth the
size of the eu one fifteenth the size of
the u.s economy
so
china may want russia as its junior
partner for cheap gas or cheap oil but
let's not pretend it's anything else
appreciate it i think we have to wrap it
up because we have to head back and do
some work thank you both so much for
joining thank you thank you thank you
thank you
okay
okay i just have one item for all of you
at the top a week ahead
uh this weekend including presidents day
on monday the president will remain in
dc
uh throughout uh obviously at the white
house uh throughout next week the
president will continue close
coordination with our allies and
partners on russia's potential further
invasion of ukraine on tuesday the
president will host an event announcing
progress on restoring critical supply
chains powering clean energy
manufacturing and creating good paying
jobs and on thursday the president will
participate in a virtual g7 leaders
meeting to discuss the ongoing situation
with regard to russian ukraine and
priorities of the german g7 presidency
this year uh with that i will jump
around as much as i can she wanted to
kick us off though great thanks uh two
questions first has the president read
the russian response on ukraine and is
he giving any consideration to
mobilizing additional troops here
uh well on the first part um i know that
as you all know our secretary of state
has accepted the invitation to have a
meeting with former mr lavrov or engage
with him uh next wednesday and certainly
we are continuing to review in terms of
the president's status or process there
i don't have anything to update you on
we have always said from the beginning
that we are open to sending
more troops should that be needed but i
don't have any update on that front i
appointed the department of defense and
then secondly real quick uh separatists
in ukraine uh are evacuating civilians
to russia secretary blanken warned about
this as a type of false flag operation
now that you're seeing these operations
does that mean a further invasion is
forthcoming if not inevitable well i
would first say that um
we believe we continue to believe as you
heard our secretary of state say
yesterday that
russia is positioned to attack ukraine
in the coming days and that has remains
the case uh just what the secretary said
yesterday obviously the president will
be speaking shortly to all of you at the
same time uh the door to diplomacy
remains open and it will continue to
remain open and again we uh as is
evidenced by the fact that our secretary
of state is planning to engage with uh
the the foreign minister uh but in terms
of uh in terms of these uh these reports
uh yes it is a good example of what
we're seeing or what we have long
anticipated or and long predicted for
all of you
that the russians would
take part in uh pretexts uh or steps
that would
lay a predicate uh for either war or to
create confusion or spread
misinformation on the ground about
what's actually happening on the ground
i think it's important to remember that
uh they have been we would consider uh
eastern ukraine uh
that the war had began in eastern
ukraine back in 2014. uh we're not
waiting it's it's already began back in
2014 there have been russian septus
there there have been uh efforts to uh
to to spread misinformation and to
create these uh uh pretext for some time
now but certainly we continue to watch
closely go ahead is it wise for
president zielinski to leave ukraine to
attend the munich conference uh that is
a decision for him to make but
regardless of what decision he makes he
will find a strong partner in the united
states what does the president want to
hear from the transit i think the call
is going on right now what what is he
going to talk about sanctions what what
what are they going to talk about
i think you have all seen the president
engage uh
quite a bit extensively i should say uh
in conversations video conferences calls
with his counterparts around the world
to ensure we remain
lockstep and coordinated and united
and
that doesn't happen on its own it
happens through a lot of work and effort
and a lot of direction by the president
of the united states so this is an
effort to have a conversation with his
counterparts about what we're seeing
where things stand
and continue that close coordination
that has been ongoing for months now go
ahead um one question
there's a readout from brett and amuse's
meeting yeah in the middle east and in
that readout since they discussed the
saudis collaborative approach to
managing potential market pressures if
russia invades can you give any details
was anything concrete agreed to were
there any uh promises made what does a
collaborative approach mean when it
comes to the saudis in the u.s well i
would say a collaborative approach means
uh trying to prevent impacts on the
energy markets if there is a shortage as
a result of an invasion there are lots
of ways to achieve that and that was
certainly part of the discussion uh but
i don't have any more details beyond
what was in the readout i would also
note that in the readout they also
conveyed that a big part of their
discussion was also related to yemen
also related to iran so there are a
range of topics that were discussed
is this the beginning of that discussion
about a potential collaborative approach
midway through close to a final
agreement i expect we expect certainly
our conversations with the saudis will
be ongoing and the effort will be
focused on ensuring that we're in a full
coordination to
handle any energy market pressures that
could arise go ahead thank you jen
we heard from president biden yesterday
he had not yet read the written response
from the russians assuming that he has
now has that changed his assessment at
all about the possibility of diplomacy
i think josh asked a similar question
but i would just say i don't have an
update on the internal discussions about
the russian response other than to
convey that uh as our secretary of state
uh noted yesterday uh he has accepted uh
the the uh offer to or he has he will be
engaging i should say with his
counterpart his russian counterpart on
wednesday unless of course they invade
um and there will continue to be a range
of diplomatic discussions uh i think the
secretary of state was also very clear
yesterday about the fact that we believe
that russia is positioned to attack
ukraine uh they of course uh could
change their minds uh or they could uh
decide not to and we are going to keep
the door to diplomacy open uh as as we
should um but again there's no new
assessment beyond what the secretary of
state said yesterday which was quite
forward-leaning uh as i think you would
all agree go ahead thanks jen has he was
in any way conveyed to ukraine it should
not respond to the provocation by russia
we're obviously seeing the increased
shelling that's happening right and and
they have not i think as you have seen
uh you know i think we are have been
speaking vocally and privately of course
about
our expectation of these types of
provocations
and
what their intended purpose is and
whether their intended purpose is to uh
create
confusion whether it is to create uh you
know irritation whether it is to prompt
a response uh obviously that would not
be uh a a positive step at this point
you have conveyed that privately we have
we have conveyed that certainly in a
range of ways
and let me just if i could go back to
the meeting um between the secretary of
state and land rovers that
may happen next week
what gives the administration hope that
there's still a path for diplomacy when
the president has said that an invasion
is all that certain to happen in the
next few days
well we hope we're wrong uh you know we
hope that uh if russia doesn't invade we
will be relieved um that would certainly
be a good outcome but at the same time
what's the alternative us not to uh say
we'll we will agree to diplomacy or
diplomatic opportunity any assurances
from russian officials that they won't
invade until laprove meets with
secretary clinton again kristen i think
as we've said in the past i mean it's
not just about what is said they've said
that publicly it's about what they do
and so we continue to believe that they
are positioned to invade ukraine if they
decide not to that is certainly a
positive step and we have a
responsibility to the global community
to ukrainians to leave the door to
diplomacy open i could try one more time
on zilinski we do have reporting that a
number of administration officials are
concerned about him leaving at this
critical moment obviously he's also
scheduled to meet with the vice
president has anyone in this
administration conveyed directly to
zielinski that there are concerns about
them moving right now i'm just not going
to detail any private diplomatic
conversations uh but again i'd reiterate
it's a decision uh that is up to him to
make uh that would is what we convey
privately as well uh and uh regardless
of what decision he makes he will remain
and we he will have the support of the
united states go ahead
lincoln lavrov meeting does the
administration see this as a precursor
to some kind of leaders summit or
perhaps a phone call between the
president and putin or a face-to-face
meeting
well i think where we are right now is
that um you know we're unclear we're
ready to engage in diplomacy but it's
unclear if the russians are going to sit
down in good faith and of course if uh
while we are doing everything we can to
prevent
uh war um and including having the
secretary of state willing to engage
further uh with his russian counterpart
i don't think we can get ahead of the
process or ahead of where things stand
which is our continued belief that they
are positioned to attack ukraine
in president bolsonaro of brazil met
with putin this week in moscow
he expressed solidarity with russia
i know the state department put
something out but
did the president feel betrayed by
president bolsonaro's comments and does
this affect u.s brazilian relationships
i've not discussed his comments with the
president but what i would say is that
the vast majority of the global
community is united
in their view a shared view that
invading another country attempting to
take some of their land terrorizing
their people
is certainly
not aligned with global values and so i
think brazil
may be on the other side of where the
majority of the global community stands
go ahead there's a report in foreign
policy magazine that russia intends to
target ukrainian politicians and
dissidents for assassination or arrest
are you aware of any plans to provide
security for president zielinski or
others
i've seen those reports we've seen those
reports and i i can't of course speak to
intelligence matters or hypotheticals we
would be very concerned about any
actions that would target political
critics or vulnerable populations as i
think is what that report is conveying
if i'm correct uh such as religious and
ethnic minorities or lgbtq persons uh we
have in the past uh seen russia try to
uh force acquiescence through
intimidation and repression but given
its hypothetical and i can't speak to it
further i i can't give you any
prediction of security assistance
about gas prices specifically um can you
explain if there is any the renaissance
to embrace the calls for the
gas tax holiday
well we've said every option is on the
table including that uh but a decision
has not been made is there any residence
here to do that i don't know if that's
called reticence it's just that a
decision hasn't been made in a process
yet
good thanksgiving just a quick follow-up
on the russian response has the
president reviewed it yet again i don't
have any update on that uh what i can
tell you is that uh our efforts remain
uh having continued diplomatic
conversations uh with our counterparts
in russia as is evidenced by the
secretary of state's plans for next
wednesday unless they of course invade
and the president's engagements that he
is a part of at this point in time but
uh i think it's important to note that
um you know when we
look at how we're going to engage in
diplomacy it's also important that
we look at how russia is responding
right and russia's stats of war if their
demands aren't met are inconsistent with
diplomacy so we are going to leave the
door open but uh i think the pr the the
secretary of state's commitment to or
openness to meeting or to engaging with
his counterpart as evidence of that and
i know you got a question on the call
that's happening um as we speak probably
with the transatlantic leaders uh just
on the president's framing of this does
he see this as getting the outliers on
the same page as a final check-in before
an anticipated invasion given that he
said he's expecting it within the next
several days it's a part of our ongoing
engagement so i wouldn't put it in those
terms um
he he
or we are united we are
with our allies i think you will hear
him convey that when he speaks to all of
you
shortly but it is also important to stay
in close touch i wouldn't say this is
the last time he's going to talk with
them or talk with these counterparts uh
in the coming days at all he's been
talking with
his counterparts nearly every single day
but the point we're at right now is of
course over the last few days we've seen
reports of rapid a rapid uptick of
violence violations of the ceasefire
agreement including the shelling of
ukrainian kindergarten yesterday more
and more disinformation is being pushed
out to the public we know this is
consistent with the playbook uh for
invasion uh and we believe they are
positioned uh two attacks of course it's
an important moment uh to
have a conversation with his
counterparts but i would expect those to
be ongoing go ahead uh did you
accidentally leave off of the week ahead
the president's interviews of supreme
court supreme court candidates
very good i was like i'm thinking maybe
i left something off uh well i can tell
you that um february is not that much
longer it's ten days if my math is
correct uh and we remain on track uh to
to make an announcement about of the
supreme court the the president's
election for a qualified and credible uh
nominee to serve on the supreme court ju
before the end of the month
which is that
what
poised to go on with ukraine is there
any thought
that if there is an invasion the
president would delay the announcement
of supreme court uh pick given
you know what else could be going on at
the time well you know i love
hypotheticals but what i will tell you
is that uh he has every intention of
making a decision this month uh he's on
track to do so that will mean he will
have chosen a nominee faster than any
democratic president in decades uh and
obviously he's somebody who has to as
leader of the free world and president
of the united states uh conduct business
on a number of fronts at the same time
what yes i'm jumping off of that
actually yesterday in the briefing it
was mentioned that the president is
planning to begin interviewing nominees
as soon as this week given that we are
on friday can you confirm if you did or
did not do anybody this week
i'm just not going to provide you a
day-to-day update but i can tell you
that this is not going to be that much
longer lasting because we only have 10
more days left of the month so that's
the good news and it is always a late
part of the process the interviews uh
but i'm not going to be able to give you
an update on that from here one other
thing um on covid i believe that only
four maybe five states still have indoor
mass mandates as it holds right now and
i know that you all have been saying
you're gonna follow this cdc's guidance
but is there a point where the cdc's
guidance is out of step with a vast
majority of what states across the
country are doing and how do you all
reconcile that well what i can tell you
is the cdc guidance follows data and
science um and data and science moves at
the speed of data and science uh you can
speak to any local leaders about what
their decision-making has been based on
and we certainly respect their right to
do that and respect their uh their their
uh their role in making decisions about
their communities but we've said that uh
the cdc is reviewing the guidance um
they have been doing that um and they're
gonna base uh any recommendations they
make on science the assumption that
democratic governors and republican
governors in all these states are not
facing decisions on data i can't speak
for how they're making their decisions i
can speak for how we make our decisions
from the federal government which is to
base it on data and science and the cdc
is the
federal government's uh
entity uh where we where we have all of
our data and science housed
go ahead thanks jen uh the former
minneapolis or suburban minneapolis
police officer who was convicted of
fatally shooting dante wright was
sentenced to two years
in prison today
is the president uh keeping track of
this is he aware of this sentence and
does he think that this was a sentence
that was fitting for uh for this crime
well what i can say is that dante wright
should be here with his family and loved
ones and his death was the tragic result
of a law enforcement officer's error we
know we have a long way to go uh when it
comes to criminal justice and racial
equity in this country that's why we are
committed to not only engaging
conversations about meaningful policing
reform but we also continue to ensure
that the law enforcement agencies have
the resources they need to properly
train and equip officers to protect our
communities but i'm not going to speak
to the specifics of the sentencing
outcome and then one more on the state
of the union which is obviously around
the corner can you talk a little bit
about
what specifically the president is doing
prepare for that
what tone he is hoping to set uh in that
speech what message he's hoping to send
i expect we will have more as we get a
little bit closer i will say that as the
president is in
washington d.c this weekend at the white
house uh he will of course be closely
monitoring developments uh in ukraine uh
but he will also be
you know working toward making uh
finalizing his uh decision-making
process as it relates to a supreme court
justice nominee and certainly uh
preparing for the state of the union as
well so i expect as we get a little bit
closer next week we'll have more to say
go ahead
back on russia and ukraine the the u.s
language seems to have changed from
imminent to highly likely back to
imminent again
is that because you're trying to
second-guess vladimir putin all the time
or were you closer to the escalation of
employment
would say that um several weeks ago i
think for maybe a day we used the word
imminent um and we believed we sent the
wrong message that was not intended uh
our intended message we were sending at
that time was that uh was that he was it
was an option or he was prepared too
obviously things have developed since
then uh we've seen a rapid uptick of
violations of the ceasefire agreement
we've seen an increase in troops
building at the border and certainly uh
we've seen an
escalatory actions that's why our
secretary of state went to the united
nations yesterday so what we're seeing
is uh further progress further
aggression over the last several days uh
go ahead
two questions one back to congress as
you know senate republicans are blocking
federal reserve nominees and other
nominees
they argue that they don't think those
federal reserve delays have any actual
effect
how do you respond to that
well i would say at a time where i think
everyone most people agree that
inflation and costs are uh
the top uh if not one of the top issues
for every american in the country the
argument that it wouldn't be best to
have a fully confirmed full federal
reserve board just doesn't seem to make
a lot of sense
then aunty on ukraine and the idea of
cyber attacks
on ukraine can you speak to the idea of
those attacks the effect they could have
on neighboring nato countries like
poland
and whether that kind of effect
could trigger article 5 under nato
protections or not does a cyber attack
affecting nato countries
include kind of the kind of language we
see in the nato defense
i think i'm just not going to get into a
hypothetical on that front obviously
they have a range of capacities we work
in clock step with our nato partners but
i'm not going to get ahead of any
intended actions go ahead jackie
on the attempted murder of a louisville
mayoral candidate uh the man who was
charged with this was released on bail a
couple days after this happened with the
assistance of a bail fund group
knowing that the vice president has in
the past supported bail front groups
what's the white house reaction to this
case and should there be restrictions on
which cases these bail fund groups can
help and this is a attempted murder i
would have to dig into this further
jackie and i'm happy to do that after
the briefing
the sanctions we've learned don't
include swift uh they don't target
energy so the impacts to other countries
are mitigated um you guys have
attributed this cyber attack to russia
and you're warning that the prospect of
war is uh or peace rather is pretty dim
so at what point do you break away from
the strategy
say it's not working and and do
something else impose some of these
sanctions now
well i think as we've talked about a
little bit in here our collective view
from our national security team is that
uh sanctions are meant to be a deterrent
uh they are not if you put all the
sanctions in place now what is stopping
them from invading
well again jackie i think that's our
assessment from the national security
team and uh you know that we will
continue to implement that strategy
to die before implementing them in that
case i think jackie that's in no way a
fair statement or accusation i guess if
that's what that is
what we have done what the president has
done is unite hundred
countries around the world on a strong
uh package that will be crippling to the
russian economy uh and we have done that
uh in a way where we have stood up for
the territorial integrity of uh of uh of
ukraine uh and stood with our nato
partners and allies it has always been
up to president putin and russia to
determine which path they were going to
take that has not changed but
that leadership on the world stage is
what has led to a united front and
united opposition to these actions and i
would also note that regardless of what
decision president putin decides to make
one of his intended objectives i think
as we've seen out there is to
divide uh nato uh the opposite has
happened to divide uh maybe the united
states and divide leadership at the
united states the opposite has happened
so if that was his objective he's
already not achieving that go ahead
patsy a question on iran earlier this
week more than 170 house republicans
wrote a letter to president biden
essentially saying that any new nuclear
deals with iran will meet the same fate
as the 2015 jcpoa meaning that the next
republican administration will just
nullify it uh does the administration
agree with this assessment and are you
concerned that this this may create a
further complication in the talks in
vienna which some are saying
optimistically could wrap up in near
weeks
well let me say first on the talks in
vienna um they are continue to be in the
eighth round it's a long round i guess
we could say
we feel substantial progress has been
made in the last week and it's
continuing to be made but nothing is
agreed to until everything is agreed if
iran shows seriousness we can and should
reach an understanding on mutual return
to full implementation of the jcpoa
within days anything much beyond that
would put the possibility of return to
the deal at grave risk
while i'm not certainly going to predict
or
what it would look like in a future
republican administration what i think
is an important reminder to everyone
regardless of your political affiliation
is what happens over the last four years
after the former president pulled out of
the deal which means we which we know
what happened which is we lost complete
visibility into their capabilities they
made a significant amount of progress
leaving us at the point we are at uh at
today and put us in a very difficult
position in order as we try to prevent
iran from acquiring a nuclear weapon so
regardless of your politics hopefully
people will factor that in as we look
ahead
i i don't have any information on the
letter
afghanistan
there's continued fighting between the
taliban and the national resistance
front of afghanistan which russia has
offered to mediate uh do you have any
reaction on both the conflict as well as
moscow's offer
i'd i'll check with our national
security team it's even get more thanks
everyone